[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute erfülle ich mir rat einen ganz
ganz großen wunsch denn er hat sich
schon länger babys gewünscht mädels das
sind diese kleinen köstlichkeiten und
zwar zins im prinzip brötchen mit einem
loch in der mitte und es ist schon so
ein amerikanisches rezept würde ich auch
sagen
dort sind sie ziemlich beliebt und babys
sind wirklich super zum frühstücken oder
auch zum abendbrot die kann man schön
belegen süß oder herzhaft so wie man das
gerne hat und was haben wir früher
tatsächlich immer nur gekauft und dann
halt getoastet oder in den backofen
geschoben und jetzt habt ihr heute ein
rezept von mir wie ihr sie richtig
selber machen könnt die bänke sind
wirklich super weich schön luftig und
ihr könnt sie entweder komplett fertig
backen oder ihr packt sie hell und
könnte super vorbereitet und einfrieren
also man einfache tipps sind ja echt
immer gut aber braucht natürlich halten
großes chris trier fach ich weiß dass es
bei den meisten so das problem aber wie
gesagt wenn ihr die mal vorbereiten und
dann können wir das gerne machen
der pegel steigt besteht aus einem ganz
ganz einfachen hefeteig für den hefeteig
verwende ich einen würfel hefe 1
esslöffel warmes wasser zwei esslöffel
zucker 400 milliliter milch 1 800 gramm
mehl 2 teelöffel salz und 50 gramm
butter
ich nehme jetzt zuerst die hefe hat
bekommt hier eine rührschüssel dann das
wasser dazu unterzucker aber kann ich
die zutaten erstmal verrühren
[Musik]
dem ich hier die mit dazu
dann das alte das eigene buch das eigelb
sorgt im teig dafür dass es so ein
bisschen weicher wird das ist jetzt kein
normaler brotteig weil brutal besteht
eigentlich nur aus wasser mehl hefe und
salz und jetzt noch ein gap dabei und
milch damit einfach die bg schön weich
werden
ich nehme noch das mehl und ich habe ich
jetzt einen 550 ich hab das extra nehmen
dann wegen vista damit ich keine sauerei
so habe man extra dran gedacht und ich
mache trotzdem sauerei naja ich habe
jetzt hier in 550 e mail könnt hier aber
auch zum beispiel dinkelmehl 630
benutzen oder ganz normales weizenmehl
405 damit das salz und die mutter ich
werde ja nicht die sally wenn ich nicht
sauer machen würde aber ich wäre auch
nicht die seele wenn ich sie nicht
mitmachen würde
ich mache sie auch wieder weg also alle
zutaten rein und dann einen schönen
geschmeidigen teig kneten
und wenn ihr merkt da verteidigen bis
hin zu fest ist einfach noch ein zwei
esslöffel milch dazugeben
also das ist relativ fest wenn ich ihn
so anfasse einfach noch ein schluck
milch rahm und dann wieder schön weil
ich jetzt ist der hefeteig fertig und
jetzt seht es ein richtig schöner
geschmeidiger glatter teig
jetzt freue mich ihnen zu einer kugel
ich nehme immer von außen den teig und
von den so von außen machen
jetzt nehme ich ein bisschen quatsch
dann nämlich am liebsten back trance
prey darüber kleben damit der teig nicht
austrocknet mit den teig abdecken und
für eine stunde etwa aufgehen lassen
[Musik]
der hefeteig ist jetzt richtig schön
aufgegangen
[Musik]
manche fragen mich übrigens ob in dieser
gehämmerten schüssel was hängen bleibt
wegen dem gehämmerten aber ihr seht es
bleibt nichts hängen als auch beim spiel
ist echt gar kein problem und ich finde
die schlüssel von außen echt richtig
schön wie es ausgeht aber guckt bleibt
nichts hängen
so und jetzt den teig einfach
portionieren in etwa 12 bis 16 teile je
nachdem wie groß die regel sein soll
[Musik]
passt die sind alle ungefähr 130 ich
glaube ich kann echt behaupten ich habe
ein gutes auto
so und jetzt nehmt ihr einfach die
teiglinge und formt sie zum kugeln also
immer schön von außen nach innen mit den
fingern von außen nach innen ziehen
da bekommt ihr nämlich eine schöne
glatte oberfläche und dann umdrehen und
kontrollen
ist er anderes in der coaching geografie
die wissen wo die länder fühlen und die
stellte inhalt gut im teig abmessen
augenmaß dass man die wichtigen dinge
richtig wichtig ich meine ihr könntet
selbst zu euren lehrern gehen und sagen
ich weiß nicht wo die städte sind und
die länder sally weiß dass audi schnitt
schlimm weil dann müsste zumindest eick
abschätzen können
aber bei uns war schon so ich war immer
ganz gut und französisch das hatte ich
auf der schule und dann mussten wir die
länder und ich stellte und so weiter
übersetzen oder weil ein land und als es
war eine karte ohne beschriftung und wir
mussten praktisch auf französisch die
länder und städte hin schreiben und ich
hab halt geschrieben schweiz auf
französisch und es war auch richtig
übersetzt aber es war leider
großbritannien
ich habe leider keinen punkt gekriegt
aber ich finde meine lehrerin wird
zumindest punkte bekam dafür die
richtige besetzung ich meine biografie
schon was anderes
es ging ja nicht um eine geografische
kenntnisse das ging ja um meine
sprachkenntnisse und nach dem formel
denke ich jetzt die teiglinge nochmal ab
mit einem tuch und lasse noch mal etwa
eine halbe stunde aufgeben
der teig noch mal schön aufgegangen und
jetzt gibt es verschiedene möglichkeiten
um die bagels zu formen
entweder nimmt jetzt im biegel drückt
ihn ein bisschen flach und nehmen zum
beispiel einen holzstab bis oder silikon
starb sofort ein loch hinein und dann
könnt ihr da nämlich mit den fingern das
loch ein bisschen öffnen
man könnte das loch einfach so ein
bisschen ausweiten oder kennst doch ganz
einfach mit einer spritztour oder einem
kleinen gläschen ausstechen
das geht auch
[Musik]
das loch in der mitte sorgt übrigens
dafür dass man eine kürzere bauzeit hat
und man hat natürlich auch mehr koste
als jetzt bei einer buchung brötchen
habe ich hier im topf mit wasser
aufgestellt da kommt jetzt ein bisschen
honig rein das ist auch so der typische
geschmack von den weg
die sind aus mehr so leicht süßlich das
war's kurz kochen lassen
[Musik]
und wenn es kocht kommen dann die mädels
da rein und werden für ein paar sekunden
im heißen wasser gebadet
[Musik]
dann hole ich es heraus und setzte auf
dem backblech
und dann bestreite ich die babys mit
eiweiß und taucht sie dann in eine
mischung aus mohn und sesam
da könnt ihr natürlich auch nur nehmen
oder nur sesam ihr könnt sie mit
kräutern bestreuen oder auch mit
sonnenblumenkernen zum beispiel das
bleibt euch überlassen
[Musik]
ich finde es so schon richtig gut aus
unser könnten direkt in den backofen
[Musik]
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr wenn ihr
einen darf backofen habt noch dampf
stufe eins dazu geben dann kommt man
leichter dampf stoß ab und zu und dann
wird die krusten humane bis in der
schüler
ansonsten einfach weglassen
[Musik]
die bagels gebacken ich habe sie
teilweise ein bisschen helm gepackt denn
die werde ich dann einzeln einfrieren
und dann wenn wir sie essen wollen
können wir aufbauen und trösten oder wir
können sie direkt im backofen einfach
packen so jetzt darf jemand das den
pegel problem der mann essen auch zu
schätzen
also ich belegte jetzt dann denke ich
hoffe geschmacks habe ich viel schief
geschnitten aber naja aber ich sehe ja
ganz gut zu machen wie schön weich dave
max olex und frische euro
kennst du bagels habe ich glaube zwar
immer so gewesen nicht aber nicht selbst
gemacht gerne oder waren sie schon hart
wenn ja wie stark das team selbst
gemacht mit setzte das ja so gibt es
etwas was du nicht magst gut ist
natürlich auch nicht
sie haben ich mag das ja machen essen
gab es schon etwas was du nicht macht
ist ich bin echt nicht besser wenn du
sagen ich bin traurig
okay das war bislang erst ein gemüsebett
so dann max
dies kann man übrigens auch süß belegen
schmeckt auch gut
nein das war keine produktplatzierung
besuchten jetzt sowie in den cafés
unserer nur so schön zu machen
diese schnittlauch
[Musik]
cook
ein paar fernseh ja was ist auch ich und
auch sonst gerade aus dem open oder ja
also ich hab den jetzt noch mal kurz
rein damit eher warm ist für dich die
anderen sind hier die sind schon ein
bisschen abgekühlt
[Musik]
und
ich weiß ja wo wir noch mal um sicher zu
gehen ob es wirklich schmeckt wie ist
ihr für diese momente koche und backe
ich sehe gerade glücklich du bist habe
mir gerade so soweit und man könnte das
auch gut belegen das haben wir unsere
guten
das ist die sind echt super lecker also
wirklich perfekt also falls ihr die nach
machen wollt dann schaut nochmal das
rezept an auf sallys - blog de auf
interesse gibt es die rezepte übrigens
auch von mir da können dass sie können
gern mit video sogar mit video
mit video und wenn ich sie nach macht
dann benutzt unseren hashtag dann kann
kann ich eure fotos nämlich auch sehen
und schreibt einfach mal wie ihr die
beatles belegt viel spaß beim nachmachen
muss zum nächsten mal
so gut hat sich murat nicht gefunden
habt ihr zum probieren ja aber auch
nicht so lange weitermachen wird sonst
macht er hier und wir kennen ja noch ein
fitnessstudio ein richter bekommt nur so
ins zimmer oder in die garage
machen wir alle nach dem essen sport
darüber könnten wir machen ja morgens
und abends der morath wird die zeit gern
fach hauswirtschaft mission erfüllt
[Musik]